doors burst open allowing the gurney to
come speeding through followed by a
gaggle of concerned Foundation
scientists and medical personnel
everyone was a buzz anxious at the
troubling development and fearful over
the fate of the patient lying on the
examination bed it wasn't exactly a rare
occurrence for someone working at an SCP
Foundation facility to need serious
medical treatment more often because of
a grievous injury or psychological
episode incurred whenever a dangerous
anomaly breached containment after all
working for the foundation was nothing
if not hazardous to your health but
Personnel being injured that was so
commonplace at the foundation that it
was practically mundane just another
ordinary part of the job it certainly
never garnered this much attention with
every researcher and Medicom site all
clamoring to try and assist or even just
get a look at who was on the gurney it
wasn't a member of personnel it was an
anomaly
scp-049 was sick nothing about the
plague doctor's Behavior had seemed out
of the ordinary he was normal at least
as much as a beak masked robe creature
could be until that is one morning
scp-049 had just collapsed in his
holding cell the security camera
watching him had recorded the entire
ordeal with guards alerting the research
teams and eventually calling paramedics
to come and escort the play doctor to
the on-site infirmary
scp-049 was noticeably weaker confused
even afraid some onlookers seemed to
think there's no sign of physical injury
Dr Cooper noted aloud trying his best to
examine scp-049 while the gurney was
racing down the hallways all without
touching the plague doctor's skin
directly one touch and he would die in
an instant all signs seemed to point to
something internal nobody had entered as
cp049 cell in the previous 24 hours the
security footage proved that the only
people who had even come close to the
plague doctor where authorized
Foundation staff Dr Cooper was right
there was no indication that scp-049 had
suffered any external damage if he'd
been attacked it would have been caught
by the security footage it had to be
some kind of illness the plague doctor
was slipping in and out of Consciousness
he could move and groan slightly but
only had a few fleeting periods of
Lucidity but if he was Ill what with
what was the cause any symptoms if there
had been any leading up to his collapse
must have been so subtle that they had
gone completely undetected by everyone
that had recently encountered as cp049
and was there a risk of
cross-contamination was everyone rushing
alongside or following the speeding
Gurnee now infected also as they reached
the infirmary Foundation Medics were
already waiting having prepped the area
for scp-049's arrival wearing gloves
over their hands to avoid lethal direct
skin contact the medical staff hoisted
as cp049 onto a bed just as Dr omell
arrived pushing his way through the
crowd of other researchers and doctors
who had piled into the sickbay alright
the show's over back up and give him
some room to breathe elmel had shouted
before turning to get a closer look at
scp-049 we've had a similar situation to
this before if it goes the same way then
there's nothing to worry about at that
moment
scp-049 briefly became Lucid once more
049 it's Dr omell can you hear me yes
yes I can the plague doctor replied
weekly please help me doctor well I'll
do my best omel said trying to keep the
beak's surgeon spirits up it's a real
good thing I was here that time you laid
an egg at least we know what to expect
this time right I'm not not laying
another egg
scp-049 rasped through his beak his pain
obvious in his tone what then what the
heck's going on
it happened he answered pestilence it is
the pestilence before losing
Consciousness again the entire infirmary
went deathly silent the pestilence the
vaguely defined disease that scp-049
spent his life seeking out and trying to
cure now it had infected him and could
potentially claim his life unless the
foundation could help him there was one
big problem nobody had any idea exactly
what the pestilence really was except
for
scp-049 the next few hours were a
Non-Stop circus an emergency quarantine
order was issued as everyone that had
accompanied the gurney had to be
screened and tested for any possible
signs of contagion if the pestilence had
actually managed to infect scp-049 there
was a high chance it could spread
especially with so many research staff
and Medics present the infirmary was
sealed off any of the Medics who were
cleared were issued a hazmat suit so
they could continue to Aid the sick
plague doctor although confirming that
staff were 100 clear of the pestilence
wasn't exactly straightforward nobody
knew what signs or symptoms to even look
for normally it was only scp-049 and him
alone that could sense the presence of
the pestilence in a human being and his
only cure was turning them into a
zombified instance of
scp-049-2 a momentary Panic started to
spread amongst the foundation Personnel
who had been near
scp-049 stemming from one idea about
what the pestilence really was the
Bubonic plague it didn't seem too far of
a stretch given scp-049's appearance
resembling the clothing worn by medieval
plague doctors when the Black Death
ravaged most of Europe during the 1300s
given that the Bubonic plague was fatal
once this paranoid rumor set in amongst
the foundation's staff some began to
break down believing they had contracted
the deadly medieval infection however
after several hours of additional
screening and testing nobody on site
showed even a hint of Bubonic plague in
their systems but all the while
scp-049 wasn't getting any better we're
still in the dark here Dr Romel said his
frustration fogging up the visor of his
hazmat suit if the pestilence isn't
Bubonic plague then what the hell is it
then how do we cure it I've been going
through the archives every interaction
that scp-049 has ever had that we've got
recorded and so far there's nothing
conclusive Dr Cooper replied swiping
through various incident reports on a
tablet all the foundation had ever truly
known of the pestilence was based on
scp-049's own testimony they were aware
it was an Insidious infection capable of
ultimately causing death in a subject
that a head contracted it but anyone
that scp-049 had ever operated on and
turned into an
scp-049-2 zombie hadn't previously
exhibited any anomalous or even just on
you usual symptoms the plague doctor had
only ever described the disease in vague
terms and he alone had been able to
sense it I went back over Dr Ham's notes
after his interview with scp-049 Cooper
continued based on these it looks like
there are a few working theories about
what the pestilence really is but but
what homel replied come on out with it
well they're pretty abstract to say the
least the fellow Foundation researcher
admitted The Entity is at the top of his
list you're kidding Dr omell's side The
Entity was something that the foundation
had long been aware of but had no way of
confirming if it even existed it had
been learned about from scp-5000 a
heavily damaged absolute exclusion
harness the suits data logs told of an
alternate timeline when the SCP
Foundation turned on humanity and began
using various anomalies to commit a
worldwide apocalypse this had been done
according to the information recovered
from the harness in order to combat a
being known only as the entity or it
apparently this being had managed to
latch on to the human Race's collective
subconscious and had been manipulating
the entire planet for some nefarious
reason the entity was what caused humans
to feel pain and subsequently fed on
that pain although nobody was aware of
its intentions the foundation of this
scp-5000 timeline had deemed it to be so
diabolical that they had resorted to
wiping out Humanity at all costs to
prevent The Entity from ever succeeding
I think it's a theory with legs one of
the Medics chimed in that can't be it's
so dumb Dr Romel replied dismissively
scratching his head exactly it's so dumb
but so brilliant the medic replied no
it's just dumb homel shouted Dr homel's
right according to the logs from
scp-5000 The Entity affects everyone Dr
Cooper pointed out but scp-049 doesn't
attempt to operate on everyone it means
if it was trying to combat the end D
would have to cure every human being
alive where are we at with treating
scp-049 Dr omell asked the longer we
spend yakking and doing nothing he could
be getting even closer to death ah we're
seeing no chance the medic answered
solemnly the foundation's immediate
course of action was to administer
scp-049 with a single dose of scp-500
also known as the Panacea coming in the
form of a red pill
scp-500 was known to cure a person of
all diseases but as we know Panacea
doesn't have one consistent rate of
Effectiveness the Medica explained it
can take longer to heal subject
depending on the disease they've been
infected with so
scp-500 could be working Dr Romel asked
like I've said we've not detected any
change in scp-049's condition the medic
replied it could be that the treatment
isn't working at all because it can't
isolate the pestilence on the plague
doctor system as far as scp-500 might
know there's nothing for it to actually
heal great really that's just wonderful
we have a miracle Carol that works on
any illness and it's just not doing what
it's meant to
home outside what about next of kin any
luck there these notoriously good at
evading capture believe me I know but if
we tell them what's going on not my
department the medic Shrugged I'd say
the fact nobody's brought him in yet
means that our field agents still
haven't found him but your guess is as
good as mine oh very insightful Dr Romel
said his frustration coming out as
sarcasm just get the hell out of here
and see what you can do for scp-049 and
send someone else to give us updates
next time hold on omel Dr Cooper
interjected take a look at Dr Ham's
notes and I've come up with another
theory about the pestilence here well
what is it's death the room felt quiet
death as in the fundamental mental law
of the entire universe the entire state
of not being alive homel exploded with
outrage disbelief listen what if
specifically dying of natural causes
could itself be the pestilence ham was
pretty old when he first interviewed
scp-049 right and they had a number of
sessions together until one day scp-049
turns on him senses the pestilence and
gives Dr Ham the whole treatment he
zombified him I know you don't need to
be koi Koopa right well during their
very first interview at site 19049 said
he could sense a lot of death there but
not all had that many traces of the
pestilence the researcher explained so
what if scp-049 had started to realize
the odd little signs of Dr Ham aging
graying hair wrinkles The Usual Suspects
and instead of waiting for him to die he
cured him immediately here in an
interview 049 said the following do you
wait to remove rotten Timbers until the
hall collapses on top of you no you find
them and you pull them out and replace
them with those Untouched by rot and
most of all you do not simply mock this
structure because it now looks different
to you it is strong it is free of
disease but not everyone is killed or
cured has been Ham's age there's no way
he would have spotted that pattern no
male reason and if he was trying to stop
people dying he wouldn't start out his
procedure with that lethal Touch of his
think about it though how does scp-049
cure people you said it yourself he
zombifies them he reanimates them we're
all infected to him everyone dies after
all so he cures that with those horrific
resurrections and thus here's death a
flabbergasted Dr omell finish the
sentence so assuming you're right and
the pestilence really is just death
itself SCP is in the other room dying
from complete deadly natural causes and
that might be the only thing even we
can't fix Dr Cooper nodded solemnly till
death to the o5 council omel muttered
suddenly one of the Medics a different
one as requested came bursting into the
room sir the next of kin one of the
field agents has recovered as cp049-j
the plague doctor was quickly rushed
into an operating theater while doctors
omel and Cooper watch from Beyond a
glass screen a shorter version of
scp-049 his son
scp-049-j was guided into the room the
little plague doctor timidly approached
its father are you sure this will work
Dr Cooper asked I read the file on
scp-049-j apparently despite all its
claims of being a magical wizard doctor
he's never actually healed anything made
a few conditions even worse in fact I
was around when Junior over there was
born Dr Romel said you know what scp-049
said to me when his egg hatched what he
is the cure that's how I know this is
going to work now go check out scp-049
boiled scrambled and fried plague Dr
tale and a day in the life of scp-049